[inaudible]
what if we humans could live somewhere outside of earth?
Say the moon.
Obviously we can't just pack our stuff and move today,
but what if we tear a formed it reshaped it into Earth's image?
How long would it take us to turn our natural satellite into a habitable place?
What would this Earth Moon looked like?
Would this even be possible?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if we terraform at the moon wondering why we chose
the moon and not Mars with water.
Ice Buried beneath surface.
The Red Planet seems to be the best candidate to serve as our second earth,
but with zero experience terraforming,
we should consider colonizing our natural satellite first.
It gets twice as much sunlight as Mars and it's just a three day trip from us.
In short,
it would take us less time and money to construct a decent earth on our moon.
So how exactly do we engineer a habitable planet?
Just to be clear,
we're not talking about building a permanent moon base.
We'd go nuts and actually transform the moon into an earth.
Just a smaller one for starters would need to build an atmosphere and here's the
fun part.
To do that,
we'd need to bombard our moon with a hundred water,
ice comments,
ice droids.
We'd find them flying all around the earth.
These comments would crash into the moon surface.
They'd fill the moon's planes with water and disperse carbon dioxide along with
water vapor and a little bit of ammonia and methane.
All these gases would gather near the surface,
creating an atmosphere the newly formed sees would reflect much or sunlight
making.
The Moon appear five times brighter when seen from earth.
These asteroids would also give the moon a momentum.
They'd make our satellite spin close to an earthquake cycle.
The more comments we batter into the moon,
a faster it would rotate.
A Lunar Day would drop down from an incredible 28 earth days to just 60 hours.
Since our satellite wouldn't rotate on its access at the same rate,
it orbits the earth anymore.
It would no longer be tidally locked to our planet.
For earthers.
This would mean we'd be able to see the dark side of the moon,
although it wouldn't be dark,
but how do we save the newly built lunar atmosphere from being stripped away by
solar winds?
We'd have a couple of options.
The first one is easy moon's own rotation would generate a dynamo effect that
dynamo could awaken the moon's once active magnetic field that would keep the
atmosphere in place.
If that doesn't work out,
we'd have to place a gigantic shield in orbit.
That shield would work as an artificial bow shock making up for a missing
magnetic field when that's all sorted,
we'd bring in genetically engineered plants suitable for growing on the moon
stony ground.
We'd also dropped some algae that would release oxygen into the air.
That would be the start of life on the moon.
Finally,
after many decades of hard and costly work,
we'd send the first human Connie to settle down on the first manmade planet.
The terraform moon would get very warm from greenhouse effects.
It would be mostly cloudy too,
and with tides as high as 20 meters surfers might want to make the trip.
Living on the moon would be just like living in Florida,
but with one sixth of the Earth's gravity,
the moon settlers would be able to jump as high as three meters off the ground,
remaining in the air for four seconds,
and if they were really fit and full of stamina,
they'd be able to run across the moon's lake.
This is because running on the water requires less muscle power.
If you do it a reduced gravity,
would you move to the moon to experience all that.